Did you know that these Hip Hop
legends went to high school together?
Jay-Z, Biggie Smalls, and Busta Rhymes
all attended George Westinghouse Career
and Technical High School in downtown Brooklyn.
Busta Rhymes and Jay-Z actually
had a rap battle in the cafeteria.
Both Jay and Busta admitted
that Jay-Z won the battle.
Busta Rhymes said that at the time
they were experimenting with speed rap,
which took less influence from New York hip-hop
and more influence from Jamaican Dancehall
artists like Lt. Stitchie and Papa San.
When the two high schoolers faced off in
the lunch room, Busta Rhymes said he had
just started experimenting with speed
rap, and Jay-Z had already mastered it.
But today it’s Busta Rhymes that’s famous
for his fast verses on his hit songs.
So we think it would be fun
to see their rematch today.